in this video we're going to be talking
about speaking in an engaging way we're
going to be talking about how do you get
people to listen to you to hear what you
have to say but more importantly how do
you speak in a way that's Dynamic and
charismatic and ultimately totally
natural something that is just you being
you instead of you trying to put on a
Persona that you're not that's the
mission how do you feel like yourself
and yet engage the audience in a way
that is very Dynamic and very very
engaging well the truth is everyone can
do it and it comes down to a concept
called musicality which is one of the
four fundamentals of speaking that we
cover in this fundamental series the
first one is confidence how do you feel
confident being yourself in moments
where you feel unprepared in this video
we're going to be talking about how do
you speak in a way that is musical that
is engaging to the ear in a way that
feels like yourself and here's the
common theme we want all of these
fundamentals to feel like you because
when you feel like you everything
unfolds organically the problem is that
Under Pressure our musicality tends to
shrink whereas at home we could be
really Dynamic and show so many sides of
our personality at work we might feel
like our range is constricting like
we're much more formal much more serious
much less willing to crack a joke or to
interrupt somebody even in the way that
we sit at home might be like so much
more relaxed and then at work it might
be so much more
formal so much more controlled and when
we try to control our range well what
tends to happen is we can strain it and
by constraining it we're much less
likely to be dynamic and to express the
full range of our personality and I
think that's the key I think the key to
being to being more engaging is to
express
diverse ranges of your personalities my
favorite speakers do this all the time
if I could construct the perfect speaker
for example I would take Tony Robbins as
passion and conviction I would take
Bernay Brown's vulnerability and and
emotional range her thoughtfulness I
would take Jennifer Lawrence's sarcasm
and quirkiness and just her ability to
like be weird I'd take Gary vaynerchuk's
just passion and ability to speak super
fast but what I would really be taking
from all of these people is their
natural ability to be themselves
because from my perspective if you
watched interviews of all your favorite
speakers they're pretty consistent what
you see is what you get and if I tried
to be Jennifer Lawrence I wouldn't be
able to be that quirky it's maybe not my
style if I tried to be loud and big like
Tony Robbins it would come across as
fake but what I can do is try to figure
out what are my versions of conviction
what's my interpretation of of humor how
can I be more vulnerable and open and
one of the ways to do that is to share
more of you share more of your emotions
and share more of your stories with
people because at the end of the day
what all our favorite speakers tend to
do is they're much more open about who
they are and so if they show up to
interviews or to stages or to work being
similar to how they are with their
friends and family members and that's
really the challenge is how do we show
up as ourselves in environments where
most people aren't doing that in
environments where we're trained to show
up as more more formal more professional
more more boxed in well what I find is
that those who have great executive
presence those who are really really
strong communicators and companies
actually their secret isn't some sort of
like confidence or or
I don't know their secret seems to be
ease they feel at ease being themselves
so the executive who's able to crack a
joke when the meeting starts or the
executive that's able to sit back in
their chair and feel kind of relaxed
when everyone else is a little bit on
edge most people say well yeah they're
an executive so they can feel that way
but it's a catch-22 because the fact
that they feel that way helps them
embody that presence so what they're
really doing is finding a way to feel at
ease in scenarios where other people
might feel pressure and that's really
the key to musicality it's the ability
to feel at ease expressing the different
sides of your personality and musicality
is all about dynamism it's about
contrast it's about being
multiple ways so not just serious but
having some humor every once in a while
or not just light-hearted but advocating
for an idea when you really believe in
it usually it's about having multiple
sides of your personality come through
and how do you do that well you have to
train it you have to train it in a way
where you feel safe but also safe enough
to go out of your comfort zone most of
us aren't used to speaking with
conviction if we're new to a job
most of us aren't used to having humor
in situations where we feel there's a
lot of professional pressure but what if
we were able to be more ourselves in
these environments that's really the key
to being engaging because we're in the
age of authenticity people want to see
the real you we respond to people who we
feel are being real who are being
authentically themselves one of the ways
to practice this is with a game called
conductor and conductor is a game that
essentially takes your energy and says
I'm in control of it now so when I raise
my hand to a nine you have to speak at a
nine and when I lower my hand to a two
you have to find a way to match the
intensity in a more thoughtful or calm
way and I can do whatever I want with my
hand meaning I'm in control of your
energy and intensity that's what we did
when we first started coaching clients
and what we noticed is that people would
break out of their spell of public
speaking and return to their
conversational
tone the the tone that feels like
themselves when they're with a close
friend that's really the key that's
what's so difficult is all of our
speaking issues tend to disappear when
with our when we're with our close
friends we speak in a conversational way
we share personal stories we use humor
we advocate for what we believe in
but when we enter environments where
we're not as safe or we don't feel as
relaxed our rain shrinks and we're no
longer as conversational or a bit more
formal we're no longer as funny we're a
bit more serious and every little
compromise that we make our range drops
into this box that's very very small and
so we feel quite
quite Restless in it we feel quite
constrained and so we experience all
these challenges in our speaking and no
amount of body language or hand gestures
or vocal varieties gonna solve the root
issue for people who feel like they have
a constrained range instead what we need
to learn is to expand our range in a
simulated environment in a in a way
where we still feel adrenaline but we
know that it's safe to fail and we have
to see what happens when we crack that
joke what happens when we share a
personal story what happens when we
speak with higher energy what happens
when we speak what's more thoughtful
energy
when we're able to experiment with
different styles of our personality we
notice that people respond most
favorably to moments where we're being
most ourselves the selves that we have a
tendency to want to hide to want to
brush under the rug and only show to our
close family and our close friends
behind closed doors and I get it but
we're in a different age now we're in
the age of authenticity and if we're
able to bring more of ourselves to all
of our speaking scenarios at work
networking events on dates on stage when
we're able to be ourselves speak with
more of our personality then there's a
natural musicality that'll come through
the underlying tone will be authenticity
it'll be realness it'll feel like wow
the reason this person is connecting
with me is because they're being real
they're expressing their emotions and I
can feel that so that's the formula and
I know it's easier said than done but
that's why you want to practice in a
group that can give you the feedback
that says I want to see more of this I
want you to break out of your comfort
zone here and I want to support you
while doing it so if I had to break it
down what do these speakers do
differently well number one they speak
with more conviction and energy they
really advocate for what they believe
and think of Tony Robbins energy think
of garyvee energy they're just able to
really dive in and speak with that
passion and conviction we have a whole
video on how to speak with conviction
but they're able to allow themselves to
do that but number two they're also able
to speak with more of that vulnerability
or that openness to share more personal
stories and brene brown emulates that
very beautifully Simon's neck does as
well number three they're able to show
their quirks like Jennifer Lawrence can
like any of your favorite comedians
they're so open and vulnerable but
they're quirky they show the kind of
funny sides of their personality and
they use humor as a way to feel more at
ease being themselves because that's
just an integral part of Personality for
them so they're able to show their humor
and most importantly they're able to
feel like themselves they're able to
feel like who they're speaking to
whether it's the talk show host or it's
the audience or it's just a camera
they're able to feel like that person is
somebody who can be trusted so they
speak in a way that's conversational
like they would with a close friend and
by speaking with emotion and being
conversational and being vulnerable the
musicality naturally shines through and
there's natural dynamism there's just a
way of speaking that feels like this is
the person and they're being real with
me when that happens nobody cares about
your filler words or your vocal variety
when that happens there's a subconscious
connection and we feel very very
connected to the speaker and we feel
like okay they're being real with us
they're being open and so I'm much more
likely to be receptive to what they say
and I'm much more likely to connect with
them and ultimately that's what
musicality is about it's about
connection it's about speaking with
emotion it's like what Maya Angelou said
people don't remember what you said but
they'll never forget how you made them
feel
if you want to make somebody feel
something you got to be able to feel it
yourself
feel like you care about what you're
saying feel like you want to share
something personal everything that has
emotion in it will be so much more felt
and transferred to the other side but
bottom line it's only going to start
happening when you feel at ease when you
feel relaxed and when you feel courage
to show more of who you are as a human
being with the people who intimidate you
who you feel most self-conscious about
when you're able to bring out your humor
and your quirks and your serious side
and your silly side in front of the
people who you used to feel much more
constrained around you're going to be
naturally more Dynamic you're going to
be naturally more engaging but most
importantly you're going to eliminate
the self-consciousness and the pressure
that we create in our head because
you've decided I'm gonna be me no matter
who is in front of me and that's
ultimately the mindset that turns public
speaking back into speaking that turns
it back into a conversation and that
allows us to have all of the natural
organic
assets that we have in our speaking all
of the ways that we speak when we're at
our best come through when we feel at
our best when we feel like we're
ourselves and we feel safe and supported
and that's ultimately what I hope that
each of you is going to get through
culture speaking so at the end of the
day musicality isn't just about the
highs and lows it's not even just about
the contrast it's about the willingness
to show your personality and be yourself
in the moments that matter most